welcome back everyone this is part six
in our series on Advanced behavioral
testing for nlu to this point we've been
focused on adversarial testing we're now
going to take a more expansive View and
think about the potential benefits of
training on adversarial cases the
foundational entry in this literature is
the anli paper and the associated
Benchmark as far as I know and Ali is
the first attempt to create a really
large train set that is filled with
adversarial examples that is with
examples that fooled a top performing
model but were intuitive for humans
I think it's fair to say that a l i is a
direct response to the kinds of
adversarial test results that we
reviewed in the previous screencast
where we saw nli models that were
surpassing our estimates for Human
Performance but nonetheless falling down
on very simple phenomena turning on
systematicity or compositionality in
language
so the vision for anali is that by
introducing an adversarial Dynamic into
the train set creation we can get models
that are more robust
here's how data set creation worked
the annotator is presented with a
premise sentence and a condition that is
entailment contradiction or neutral one
of the nli labels
the annotator writes a hypothesis
and then a state-of-the-art model makes
a prediction about the resulting premise
hypothesis pair
if the model's prediction matches the
condition that is if the model was
correct in some sense the annotator
returns to step two to try again
whereas if the model was fooled the
premise hypothesis pairs independently
validated by other human annotators
the result of this Dynamic of this
interaction with this top performing
model is a train set that is full of
really hard cases cases that fooled this
top performing model in addition to
cases that didn't fool that that model
the examples are kind of interesting the
premises in anali tend to be long the
hypotheses are of course challenging
interestingly the data set also contains
these reason text this is the
annotator's best attempt to explain why
the model might have struggled with that
particular example as far as I know the
reason texts haven't been used very much
in the literature but they strike me as
an interesting source of indirect
supervision about the task so you might
check those out
this is the core results table for the
analyze paper there's a lot of
information here but I think the story
is pretty straightforward let's focus on
the Bert model the Burt model is doing
really well on snli and multi-nli across
all of these different variants of the
training regimes
when the model is trained only on SNL
and multi-nli it does really poorly on
Ali you can see analy had three rounds
when we pulled them together this model
gets around 20 percent accuracy
as we take that model in augment it's
training data with anli data from
previous rounds we do see improvements
overall in the anli column which is
encouraging it looks like the models are
getting better at the task as they get
more of these adversarial examples as
part of training
but the fundamental Insight here is that
performance on Ani is well below
performance for the other benchmarks
this is a substantial Challenge and I
believe that this substantial challenge
still stands models do not excel at anli
even into this day as far as I know
one thing I love about anli is that it
projects this kind of really interesting
vision for the future development of
train and test assets for the field it's
actually all credit due to Zellers at
all they also describe this Vision in
their papers on swag and hella swag they
write a path for NLP progress going
forward towards benchmarks that
adversarially co-evolve with evolving
state-of-the-art models I didn't have
time to tell this full story in details
but Zellers at all is an interesting
story there are two papers the first one
introduced swag which is a kind of
synthetically created train and test
environment for adversarial testing
and they found that it was very
difficult but when the Burt paper came
out Bert essentially solved the swag
problem
in response to that Zellers at all made
some adjustments to the swag data set
that produced hello swag hella swag was
substantially harder for Bert and I
believe that hella swag remains a
challenging Benchmark to this day and I
think that started us on the path of
seeing how productive it could be to
create data sets use them to develop
models and then respond when models seem
to succeed with even harder challenges
and in the anli paper they project this
Vision very directly this process yields
a moving post Dynamic Target for nlu
systems rather than a static Benchmark
that will eventually saturate this
sounds so productive to me you know
throughout the field large teams of very
talented people spend lots of time and
money getting Epsilon more performance
out of our established benchmarks
wouldn't it be wonderful If instead when
we saw the Benchmark saturating we
simply created new benchmarks and post
new challenges for ourselves I think
it's a very safe bet that models would
improve more rapidly and become more
capable if we did this kind of moving
post thing
and that really is the vision for
dynabench dynabench is an open source
software effort an open source platform
for doing among other things Dynamic
adversarial data collection
and dynabench has produced a number of
data sets to this point
anali is the first one that's the
precursor we also have dynabench derived
data sets for QA for sentiment and a
number of data sets for hate speech
include including counter speech to hate
speech we have a few on QA and one on
German hate speech and I think this list
will continue to grow and offer us these
incredible new resources
so let me stop there for the next
screencast I'm going to do a deep dive
on a dynamic derived data set that we
created called dynasent